[Music]
today's motivation Monday is inspired by
a snapchat I got earlier today by an
entrepreneur who started a business
apparently nine months ago and he sends
me a message he says dad you have no
idea how hard things are right now my
wife and I are arguing I'm barely making
the rent I'm barely able to pay the car
payment I barely have any money to bank
account I need you to bail me out
because you understand what business is
all about can you lend me twenty
thousand dollars and I said twenty
thousand dollars I responded back with a
video and I said listen what did you
expect it was going to be like I'm
honestly I'm really curious like did you
expect things were going to be easy did
you expect you're going to go into
business and all of us on your
millionaire overnight living in a 5.5
million dollar house like this one
behind me did you think all of a sudden
everybody on the internet was going to
follow you your celebrity this expert
Fox News CNN everybody is going to call
you too oh my gosh what can you tell us
are the keys to success so many people
want to say imma be a million after they
rethinking Grow Rich one time they rich
that poor that how to win friends and
influence people and couple these other
books imma be a millionaire it doesn't
work that way all of us have to go
through the two five ten world it
applies to everybody and let me tell you
what it is the first two years of being
a business owner sucks not everything's
going to blow your way family's not
going to understand you your friends are
not going to understand you help the
customers are not going to believe they
know what you're doing all that stuff
you're going to go through by the fifth
year you will learn what you're doing
with business you'll have some results
you're probably making some decent money
and by the 10th here people will call
you an expert now here's the unfortunate
story 90% of people don't make it pass
it to your mark they just don't because
the moments the Batchelor bad thing
starts happening to them they think it's
only them they think nobody else is it's
just me that's why business was hard for
me you don't understand I went through
such-and-such everybody who makes it big
goes through all those things but they
overcame it and if you want to make it
you also got overcoming it's that simple
now here's the other side of the story
as well if you are truly willing to be a
pro if you're not afraid of hard work if
you're not afraid of costly working on
yourself if you're not afraid of costly
figuring out a way to develop yourself
if you don't
off when momentum comes your way and all
of a sudden business is growing you
start thinking you're big in a momentum
if you don't do those things you will
actually have a shot at building a
significant business where one day the
world is going to call you an expert one
day but you got to go through the two
five ten rule in order for you to be
experiencing what I'm telling you about
so my challenge to you today is this
are you really you I'm talking to you
I'm not talking about I'm talking to you
do you really want to go through this
two five ten party you're really willing
to do this because if you do you got
some good stuff waiting for you two five
ten years from now
[Music]